Trust the process!
He is close, my lord
Excellent, thank you
Burn the witch!
Fire Sam now!
I don't want more picks
I wanna win!
I wanna be in the playoffs!
Off wif his head!
You suck!
You lied to us!
There's no process!
You're just a loser!
It's time, Sam!
I just need a moment!
They say an analytics man doesn’t have a heart
But I ran the numbers,
and nothing could be further from the truth
You are a son to me, Joel
Know that I will always be watching you
I will always believe in you
Please, forgive me for leaving
I have no choice
Sam, open the door
You will be the light that pulls this city from the darkness
The fruits of the process will soon ripen,
and the harvest will yield
great things
Open the damn door, Hinkie!
Get the battering ram!
And no matter what
you must always
ALWAYS
TRUST THE PROCESS
Remember! Make sure the hold on to
Robert Covington!
Get your hands off me!
Always take the best player available!
Hey, be careful with the lottery spheres!
Every pick has value!
Maintain the long view!
Value optionality!
You suck, Colangelo
Bring back Sam now!
Your maester staff is terrible
Hinkie died for our sins!
Fire the Colangelos!
Ugh, these damn Philadelphia fans
Always so angry
They should be grateful!
I got a first-round pick for Nerlens!
Okay fine, top-18 protected, but Sam always said–
Oh dear, the fanlings have breached the castle walls
It’s going to be fine, father
Okafor is guarding the door
Holdin’ the door
hold the door
hol’ dadoor
oka door
oka foor
Okafor
Okafor!
That’s my n–
Draft Markelle Fultz!
GO FOR THE HOAGIES! GO FOR THE HOAGIES!
Yo, watch it man, you’re spilling my water ice!
Agholor can't even catch
Oh yo, look at this! Hey guys! Embiid’s on the table
Yo! Paint a picture with me and Embiid, yo right here